[Music]
The Only Thing Worth stealing is the
kiss of a sleeping
child for some of us happiness comes
while we
sleep the Potter sleeps soundly for no
one will steal
clay men and women sleep on the same
pillow but have different
dreams sleep is the Wish Your Heart
Makes when you are fast
asleep free time is those five or 6
hours when you sleep at
night your future depends on your dreams
so go to
[Music]
sleep sleep is the golden chain that
links health to your
body a good laugh and a long sleep are
the best medicines in the doctor's
book when I'm at work I can fall asleep
instantly but when I'm in my bed I can
hardly
sleep if a person had as many ideas
during the day as during insomnia he
would be
rich
some people can't sleep because they
have insomnia I can't sleep because I
have
internet a sleeping Fox counts chickens
in his
dream happiness is waking up looking at
your watch and finding you have two more
hours of
sleep your eyes water when you yawn
because you miss your bed and you feel
sad the soul of the righteous
contemplates the mysterious sky in a
dream our birth is just a dream and
[Music]
Oblivion you know you're in love when
you can't sleep because reality is
better than your
[Music]
dreams never go go to bed angry stay on
your feet and
fight every night when I go to bed I die
and the next morning when I wake up I am
reborn laugh and the whole world laughs
with you snore and you sleep
alone even the soul immersed in sleep
working hard and helping makes something
out of the the
[Music]
world sleep is the most innocent
creature there is and a Sleepless man
the
guiltiest if you can't sleep get up and
do something instead of lying around and
worrying you get anxiety not
insomnia life is what happens when you
can't
sleep there are five main facts in life
birth food sleep Love and
Death sleep at odds with broken hearts
there will be nothing to do with
them the best cure for insomnia is to
sleep a
lot sleep is like a cat it only comes to
you if you IGN ignore
it never waste time that you can spend
sleeping everything seems possible at
night when the rest of the world is
[Music]
asleep sleep is the single most
effective thing we can do to restore the
health of our brain and
[Music]
body fatigue is the safest sleeping pill
as important as it is to have a plan for
getting the job done perhaps even more
important is having a plan for rest
relaxation self-care and
sleep when you wake up with a song stuck
in your head it means that an angel has
been singing to you to fall
asleep always go to bed in cute pajamas
you never know who you will meet in your
[Music]
dreams a dream is a skillful magician it
changes the proportions of things the
distances between them it separates
people as they lie side by side brings
them closer and they barely see each
other both sleep and insomnia if they
are excessive are
[Music]
harmful in whatever disease sleep may be
difficult it is a deadly symptom but if
sleep is beneficial it is not
[Music]
fatal I really like it when a bad dream
doesn't scare you but inspires
you when things go wrong the strongest
take a
nap
[Music]
no wonder Sleeping Beauty looked so good
she slept long never got old and didn't
have to do anything but snore to get her
prince
charming I always say morning instead of
good morning because if it were a good
morning I would still be
[Music]
sleeping don't give up on your dreams
too early sleep
longer
[Music]
a day without sleep is like a cupcake
without
[Music]
icing there is no day so bad that it
cannot be corrected by a good
[Music]
nap insomnia is a glamorous term for the
thoughts you forgot about during the
day I tried counting sheep to sleep but
it got boring so I started talking to
the shepherd
[Music]
instead the best bridge between Despair
and hope is a good night's
sleep when you lie down you will not be
afraid your sleep will be
sweet a Wells spent Day brings a happy
[Music]
dream
A Mother's Hands Are Made of tenderness
and a sweet dream blesses the child that
lies
[Music]
within people who say they sleep like a
baby usually don't have
one joy and sorrow sleep in the same
bed babies smile in their sleep because
they listen to Angels
Whispering there are hard days in
motherhood but the sight of a sleeping
baby reminds you why it's worth
it poor men sleep the
best silence is the sleep that nourishes
wisdom sleep is the best
[Music]
meditation people who snore always fall
asleep
[Music]
first he who sleeps on a silver bed
dreams of
[Music]
gold get up first in the morning and go
to bed last in the evening for those who
sleep do not catch
fish to fulfill a pipe dream try to fall
[Music]
asleep having sex with your ex in your
dreams can mean that you are feeling
unfulfilled in your current
[Music]
relationship a guard's dream is a
thief's
[Music]
flashlight the more you know the less
you will
sleep poverty is even worse if you have
to sleep on the edge of a cramped
[Music]
bed if a man threatens you sleep soundly
at night if it is a woman stay
awake if you're going to do something
tonight that you will regret tomorrow
morning stay up
[Music]
late